tickets for this year's Glastonbury sold
out in just minutes with around 200,000
people expected to celebrate its 50th
anniversary in June but music lovers
around the world affected by
cancellations and isolation have been
getting creative to ensure the music
plays on in Italy they've been singing
to raise their spirits locked-down has
led to the most magical music and
heartwarming seems now choir master
extraordinaire Gareth Malone is
determined to get Britain in tune
Glastonbury being canceled that
collective that feeling that you are
part of something a magical moment in
time we're not going to have that so we
need to find alternatives we need other
other ways to feel good about ourselves
Gareth is formed countless choirs around
the country and is famed for bringing
people together through music
loneliness is going to be a very big
problem the virus itself is it's just
one problem
mental health is going to be a huge
issue I think I've becoming months and I
think we are in for the long haul so
Gareth is going digital appealing to the
public and professionals to join his
great British home chorus and musicians
around the globe are also engaging
Coldplay's Chris Martin has been
streaming free gigs from his living room
with John Legend doing the same and
bands like kodaline who've been forced
to cancel concerts are looking at
releasing material online social media
and in this day of age it's actually is
probably exciting to see what musicians
and create different creative people
will come up with online keeps morale
and it keeps people coming together you
know something positive to come out of
something so scary I suppose in a way so
musicians will be adapting and
harnessing the power of music in the
months to come
Lucy Cotter Sky News